well now to developing news about a
coronavirus vaccine the united kingdom
becoming the first country to approve
pfizer's vaccine with the first
vaccinations set to happen in just
days laura ingall live for us in malvern
new york
laura hey trace you know while we have
at least a week to go
before we hear what the fda will do
about the
pfizer candidate here in the united
states
we heard from the health and human
services secretary alex azar
saying that this is actually great news
what's happening in the uk
for us here in america here's what he
told fox business
last hour the british approval is just
great news in the sense that for the
american people
this should be very reassuring an
independent regulatory authority in
another country has found this vaccine
to be safe and effective for use
the cdc's advisory committee voted just
last night to recommend
front line health care workers as well
as residents of long-term care
facilities
to get top priority in the first days of
any approved
vaccination program now the panel of
outside scientific experts voted 13-1
to put those two groups at the front of
the line when the shots are ready to go
here's what one of the committee members
said of the importance of his vote
one of my favorite people muhammad
gandhi said a nation's greatness
is measured by how it treats its weakest
members and i feel prioritizing health
care providers
and prioritizing residents of long-term
care facilities
represents the right decision at this
time
now when we're talking about these two
groups that's about 24
million people in those two categories
the recommendations which are not
binding have been handed off to the cdc
director
for approval that is expected to happen
today the cdc is also expected to
release revised
guidance on quarantine time for those
who may have been exposed to the
coronavirus and have tested
negative they're looking at moving that
from 14 days to 7 days
and then 10 days for those who have not
been tested
again the cdc director is expected to
have a meeting this hour
we'll pass along any information as we
get it trace yeah it's all key stuff
laura ingall live for us in new york
laura thank you